Speaker 3: Hi.
I was just kind of wondering what you think
about what's going to happen in midterm elections?
I mean, I'm not looking too much at like polls
at this point, but just from my perception,
I feel like Democrats are getting a lot less
popular.
A lot of people, you know, are blaming Biden
for the gas bill or the gas prices.
And I just feel like if they don't do anything
about it, they're going to stay very unpopular.
I was wondering if you thought that they were
either aware of it or like what you would
recommend.
Speaker 1: So I think Democrats are aware
of it.
So so there's two sides to this.
Austin, the first part of it is historically,
and if you can do something to turn off the
discord blinks, that would be really great.
I don't know if you're using push to talk
or if you haven't silence notifications, but
I would love your help with that.
So on the one hand, for historical reasons,
typically when a party wins the White House,
then the next midterms aren't good for them.
So like historically speaking, Democrats should
should lose at least control of the House
or Senate in November.
On the other hand, we have this situation
where in 2016 and 2020 you had a lot of Trumpists
voting who never voted before Trump.
They only got involved in politics because
of Trump.
And it remains an open question whether there
is going to be a sort of a disappearance of
many of those individuals, and they're not
even going to vote in November.
The other question is we know COVID has killed
more Republicans than Democrats.
To what effect will the Partizan death gap
of COVID affect Republicans, so Democrats
should be losing?
Historically, Joe Biden is also getting blamed
for stuff that's not his fault, like gas prices.
That's that those are not good things for
them.
But I think it's such a unique midterm that
it remains to be seen.
I don't really have a prediction.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Do you think that though, like certain parts
like, I don't know, do you think, do you see
kind of the new like decriminalization of
marijuana bill is like something that they
might be putting forth to kind of reclaim
some popularity because I just feel like from
the perspective, like they have not really
gotten anything done with like the infrastructure
bill being gutted and they're not really doing
anything popular like as of right now or making
an effort to.
Speaker 1: I think that time is quite short
and it would be really great for Democrats
if they want to do well to try to get something
else major done.
But to be perfectly frank, it's not seeming
to me like they're they're going to be able
to do it.
So they're going to have to run on convincing
people based on what's already happened.
And that's quite frankly, it seems like that's
going to be a difficult thing to do.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I kind of just wish they
had more control over, you know, getting policies
that are popular, but obviously there's a
lot of, I guess, red tape within the party.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and there's also a limited
amount of political capital.
The one thing I will say is I don't really
think Joe Biden has much of an interest in
doing student loan forgiveness, but he still
could look at doing something like that.
And maybe the new moratorium on payments until
August is him saying, Well, maybe in August,
I'll do some student loan forgiveness, which
will help us in November.
That was Pat's idea on a recent bonus show.
I don't know.
I don't know, but I think it's an interesting
question.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Well, thank you for your time, I definitely
agree that Biden should be doing some kind
of like emergency kind of catch up.
I feel like you're just catching a lot of
flak for inflation and gas.
And like, I obviously don't have like any
like concrete evidence on this.
But just from what I've seen living in, like
Florida, I'm at the University of Florida,
but I'm from Miami.
Just a lot of like A. Biden sentiment.
Let's go, Brandon is everywhere.
Yeah.
I'm just a little worried for the future.
Speaker 1: You're right to be worried.
Austin, thank you so much for the call.
Let's go next to Jamie from Georgia.
Jamie, welcome.